Professor Christine
Hayes: I was talking last
time about the concept of
election or choice,
God's choice of Israel,
Israel as the chosen one,
which occurs for the first time
in the Book of Deuteronomy.
And I was talking about the
fact that for Deuteronomy the
election of Israel,
God's election of Israel means
or entails the idea that Israel
is a holy people,
holy in the sense of separated
to God--that root meaning of
holiness which means to be
separated from the common or the
ordinary.
So that separation entails
separation from alien peoples
and practices that are
inconsistent with the worship of
God.
So for this reason,
intermarriage with the
Canaanites is prohibited in
Deuteronomy.
And, in fact,
they are to be utterly
destroyed.
All alien practices are to be
removed from the covenant
community.
Now, given that there were
probably no Canaanites at the
time of Deuteronomy's
composition,
according to some scholars,
these texts may be understood
as a kind of internal polemic
against those elements of
Israelite society whose
practices didn't conform to
Deuteronomy's Yahweh-only
policy,
or Yahweh-only ideals.
This is an idea we will come
back to in a minute.
I just want to throw it out
here.
Separation entails also
separation to God's service.
That means, of course,
the observance of his laws,
especially the laws of purity,
the rejection of pagan
practices, and so on.
So the privilege of having been
chosen or singled out,
of being a holy people to God
entails obligations and
responsibility.
At the same time,
it's interesting that
Deuteronomy seems to be aware of
some of the dangers in this
idea,
the danger of a superiority
complex, a moral danger involved
in the notion of election.
So Deuteronomy warns
repeatedly: it is by no special
virtue or merit that Israel was
the one chosen.
And Moses admonishes the
Israelites not to suppose that
their inheritance of the land of
Canaan is due to their own
powers,
or on account of any
righteousness or virtue that
they possess.
In fact, he says, far from it.
Israel was chosen by Yahweh in
an act of spontaneous love--;it
does not imply her
perfection--an act of
spontaneous love for the
patriarchs.
And the election was entirely
God's initiative and is no cause
for Israel to boast.
So Deuteronomy 7,
verses 6-8 read:
For you are a people
consecrated [made holy]
to the Lord your God:
of all the peoples on earth the
Lord your God chose you to be
His treasured people.
It is not because you are the
most numerous of peoples that
the Lord set His heart on you
and chose you --;
indeed, you are the smallest of
peoples;
but it was because the Lord
favored you and kept the oath He
made to your fathers that the
Lord freed you with a mighty
hand and rescued you from the
house of bondage,
from the power of Pharaoh king
of Egypt.
So don't be tempted--Moses
later warns the
Israelites--don't be tempted to
say to yourselves (this is in
Deuteronomy 8:17),
"My own power and the might of
my own hand have won this wealth
for me," or again,
to say in Deuteronomy 9:4,
"The Lord has enabled us to
possess this land because of our
virtues."
On the contrary,
he emphasizes,
it is only because the
wickedness of the Canaanites is
so great that the Lord has to
drive them from his land,
and now he is giving you a
chance.
But it is conditional for you,
just as it was for them.
Don't fail him or he will drive
you out just as he drove out the
Canaanites.
That's a theme in Deuteronomy.
We are going to see in a moment
how important that is,
or in a few lectures,
how important that idea is for
the Deuteronomistic historian in
general.
But we will get there.
Another theme in the Book of
Deuteronomy is the theme of
providential concern,
and that appears in Deuteronomy
8.
God's providential love and
care for Israel is expressed
through various metaphors in the
Bible.
And the prophet Hosea,
who seems to have very strong
connections with the Book of
Deuteronomy,
the prophet Hosea will develop
further this image of parent and
child that occurs in Deuteronomy
8.
So in a way,
the language we were just
referring to was really the
language of husband and wife,
you know, someone who simply
loves someone,
not because they are perfect,
but that is their choice.
They favor them.
They love the person,
and they make a bond with them.
It does not imply anything
about other people.
It is simply that is the person
who has been the focus.
So we have a lot of sort of
love and marriage imagery,
husband and wife imagery,
used for God and Israel,
but we also have this parent
and child imagery that appears.
In Deuteronomy 32:10,
the image is that of an eagle
that bears its young on its
wings:
He found him in a desert
region,
In an empty howling waste.
He engirded him,
watched over him,
Guarded him as the pupil of his
eye.
Like an eagle who rouses his
nestlings,
Gliding down to his young,
So did he spread his wings and
take him,
Bear him along on his pinions;
The Lord alone did guide
him.…
It almost seems to play on the
idea that when teaching its
young to fly,
the eagle will push them out of
the nest, swoop under them,
bear them up for awhile over
and over until they get the
idea.
So God is repeatedly testing
and correcting the Israelites
until they are ready for the
Promised Land.
So Deuteronomy's content,
which are these farewell
speeches and the death and the
burial of Moses,
are a fitting capstone to the
Pentateuchal narrative.
But at the same time,
Deuteronomy really does not
bring closure to this narrative,
because at the end of
Deuteronomy, the promises still
are not fulfilled.
The people are still outside
the land.
Some have suggested that this
is quite purposeful.
It points to an exilic date for
the work's final composition:
that is to say when it was
finally redacted,
the redactors were in exile,
writing for a people living in
exile.
And the Deuteronomist wants to
make it clear that it is
fidelity to the Torah,
rather than residence in the
land that is critically
important.
But in any event,
Deuteronomy is not simply the
concluding book of the
Pentateuch, or the story that
began in Genesis;
it's also the first part of a
much larger, longer literary
work, as I mentioned last time,
a work that runs from
Deuteronomy through to the end
of 2 Kings.
And we are going to consider
today the program and the work
of this so-called
Deuteronomistic school.
But before we do that,
I wanted to just make a few
concluding remarks about source
theory and the Pentateuch.
We have talked about the
Documentary Hypothesis.
different sources that scholars
believe they have been able to
identify as comprising the five
books of the Pentateuch.
And one of the things I
mentioned a couple of times are
some of the debates that occur
on the question of dating.
There is a great deal of
ideological baggage that is
involved in the dating of the
sources.
One of the issues that I think
is a real problem is the fact
that the Priestly source,
P, is so often misjudged and
maligned.
I hope that the little bit of
time that we have spent on the
Priestly materials gave you some
appreciation of its
transformation of older
Israelite rituals and traditions
into symbolic practices that
would communicate basic
convictions about morality,
convictions about holiness.
I hope it gave you a sense of
its communal ethic as opposed to
an individual morality,
the idea that the actions of
every individual have an impact
on society as a whole.
But the anti-priest,
anti-cult sentiment,
of European Protestantism,
is apparent in the history of
biblical scholarship in the last
few centuries.
And it is apparent in that
scholarship's negative
assessment of the Priestly
source of the Bible.
So for Wellhausen,
the Priestly source,
which emphasizes cult and
ritual--logically it had to
represent a late degenerate
stage in the evolution of
Israelite religion,
because priestly ritualistic
cultic practices,
these are degenerations.
These are movements away from
true spirit-filled religion in
his view.
So according to Wellhausen,
the early period of ancient
Israel must have been
characterized by a free,
more natural form of religion,
an intimate relationship with
God, unencumbered or unsullied
by the legalistic cultic
obsessions of priests and cult.
He argued that in 586,
with the destruction of
Jerusalem and the people were
taken into exile in Babylon,
that was when,
in Babylon, the priests were
able to assume control,
and they were able to play on
the exiles' overwhelming
feelings of guilt and failure.
The priests were able to
construct a new identity and
religion that stressed the
sinfulness of the people,
and the need for ritual purity
and ritual observance and
legalism as the road back to
God.
And they were able to write
themselves back into the
narratives and stories of
Israel's past.
And this, according to
Wellhausen, was a degeneration.
Well, this reconstruction of
the evolution of Israelite
history, Israelite religion,
excuse me, is really driven
more by theological prejudice
than it is by historical
evidence.
And it stems from an obvious
projection of the
Protestant-Catholic tension onto
Israelite history.
It also is driven very much by
a secessionist account of
Judaism as being something that
was moribund at the time of
Jesus.
Jesus came and revived this as
a spirit-filled religion again,
when it had decayed and
withered and degenerated like a
dead tree, as Wellhausen refers
to it.
This isn't to say that all
scholars who date P to the
post-exilic period are motivated
by the same problematic
assumptions.
That is certainly not the case.
There are scholars of all
stripes and allegiances who view
P as late;
and there is some very good
objective evidence for dating
parts of P to the post-exilic
period,
just as there is good objective
evidence for dating parts of D
and the other sources to the
post-exilic period.
So when it comes to dating the
sources, certainly I would say
all scholars agree that the
Priestly materials reach their
final form in the exile or
post-exilic period.
So that is the sixth century,
right?
(You are going to find out,
we are going to return from
exile in the 530s,
o.k.?) So when we talk about
the post-exilic period,
we are talking about the period
after the return.
So the period of the exile is
the sixth century,
the bulk of the middle of the
sixth century.
So it certainly reached its
final form in that period ,
as did Deuteronomy,
and the Pentateuch probably
generally.
Nevertheless,
there are many data that
suggest that the Priestly
sources retain very early
strata, just as D contains
pre-exilic or early material.
P espouses a communal ethic,
and post-exilic priests are
going to turn increasingly to an
individual ethic.
Many sections of P do not seem
to assume a central sanctuary.
Remember that the idea of the
central sanctuary really took
hold in 622, with Josiah and
Josiah's reform.
So it becomes a real watershed
for us in dating texts:
texts that are happy with the
existence of shrines throughout
the land of Israel are probably
pre-Josiah, pre-622,
pre-exilic.
Texts that insist on a central
sanctuary are probably Josiah's
time or later.
And there are many sections of
P that don't seem to assume a
central sanctuary.
There are sections of P that do
seem to assume a central
sanctuary.
More significantly,
I think, P contains no
universal ban on intermarriage.
It does not employ its purity
laws or language to mark an
inseparable boundary between
classes within Israel or between
Israelites and gentile others.
The use of purity and purity
language to inscribe boundaries
between Israel and other nations
is very characteristic of the
post-exilic period.
We are going to see that when
we get there.
So it is very hard to
understand P's silence in this
regard, if it stems entirely
from the post-exilic,
priestly circles.
So I think that instead of
charting an evolution or a
degeneration--as I have over on
the side of the board- -an
evolution or a degeneration from
JE,
the pure spirit-filled
religion, to D,
the humanitarian,
ethical religion,
to P,
cultic obsessiveness and
guilt-ridden legalism,
as is done or implied in some
classical source theory (some,
not all), it may be better to
see these three as really
representing three distinct and
roughly contemporaneous strands
of ancient Israelite tradition
and experience told from their
own perspectives.
These materials were
transmitted and developed by
different circles within
Israelite society over
centuries, and they crystallized
at different times.
JE has fragments that are quite
old, but it probably reached its
final form before the
centralization of the sanctuary.
It is still comfortable with
the existence of many sacred
places throughout the land,
so probably before 622.
Deuteronomy contains northern
traditions from before the fall
of Israel, which was in 722,
but it was clearly finalized in
the exile.
There are many passages that
make it clear that it's written
from an exilic perspective.
And the Priestly source,
likewise, contains many,
many older traditions,
but reached its full and final
form in the exilic or
post-exilic period.
So each of these complex,
multi-layered sources--in each
one of them you can find
different layers--each one
possesses its own emphases,
its own agenda,
its own perspectives.
Sometimes they complement one
another.
Sometimes they challenge and
contradict one another,
but they are not best seen as
linear,
as telling a neat,
linear story about Israelite
religion flowering and fading.
Their diversity has not been
flattened or homogenized by the
final editor of the text.
It has been preserved in a
manner that stimulates
reflection and debate.
So with those concluding
remarks, we are going to move on
now to the second major section
of the Bible.
We have been discussing the
Torah, or Pentateuch,
and now we are moving on to the
section of the Bible that is
referred to as the Prophets.
This section of the Bible is
divided into two parts we refer
to as the "Former Prophets" and
then the "Latter Prophets."
The Former Prophets will
concern us for the next few
lectures.
And the Former Prophets include
the books of Joshua,
Judges, 1 and 2 Samuel,
1 and 2 Kings.
They read as a historical
narrative.
This material is a
theologically oriented account
of Israel's history from the
conquest of Canaan,
or what is represented as the
to the destruction of the state
by the Babylonians in 587-586
BCE.
This material is therefore
crucial background to reading
the Latter Prophets.
Now the Latter Prophets is a
collection of books,
each of which bears the name of
the individual whose prophecies
it purports to contain.
These prophets delivered their
oracles at critical junctures in
Israel's history,
in the nation's history,
so their words are only going
to make sense to us if we first
understand the particular
historical crises that they are
addressing.
And that historical narrative
that runs from Joshua through 2
Kings provides that information.
It tells us of the critical
junctures in the nation's
history, and that will help us
then slot the different prophets
in.
So the Former Prophets,
or the historical books,
like the books of the Bible
that we have already studied,
contain various older sources
that have been put together by a
later hand.
We have an editor or a group of
editors who reworked these older
sources.
They were oral traditions.
Some of them were probably from
royal archives and so on.
And they wove them together
into the form that we have now,
and that is a process that is
referred to as redaction or
editing.
The anonymous person or group
or school that's responsible for
the final composition,
the final redaction of these
books, would put the materials
together by inserting verses and
speeches that would frame the
older sources and link them
together,
give them some sort of common
uniting thread.
The redactors' linking and
framing passages and their
revisions of the older sources
exhibit certain common features.
They harp on the same themes
over and over again;
they use some of the same
language over and over again;
they share certain assumptions.
And those features and
assumptions have a lot in common
with the book of Deuteronomy,
a lot in common with the book
of Deuteronomy;
and that is what led the German
scholar, Martin Noth,
to surmise that Deuteronomy and
these historical books really
form a unit,
so that Deuteronomy not only
looks back and finishes off the
Pentateuchal narrative,
it looks forward as the
beginning of really the
historical account that is to
follow.
J, E and P really seem to come
to an end here;
there is some debate about
this, but because the
interpretive history that runs
from Joshua to 2 Kings is based
on ideals that are set out in
the book of Deuteronomy,
we refer to the person or the
persons who redacted this whole
unit as the Deuteronomistic
historian,
or the Deuteronomistic School.
The whole unit,
as a whole, was redacted after
622: that's clear.
It assumes and insists upon the
centralization of the cult.
The last dated event that is
mentioned in 2 Kings is
something that occurred in 562.
That was when King Jehoiachin
was released from prison in
Babylon, in 562.
So the work was probably
concluded shortly after that
date: so in exile or towards the
end of the exilic period.
Martin Noth assumed that there
was one editor.
Other scholars have assumed
that there were two,
or even more,
successive editions of this
history because there are
multiple perspectives that seem
to be represented.
But the last seems to be an
exilic perspective,
the perspective of someone
sitting in exile and we will be
returning to that in a future
lecture.
Some of the books within this
very large unit,
or at least the traditions
within this very large unit,
are less influenced by
Deuteronomy and its themes and
its concerns.
Some contain clearly
pre-Deuteronomistic elements and
materials, if you will.
But I encourage you to read the
excellent introduction to the
Prophets, the section of the
Bible "The Prophets" which was
written by Marc Brettler in your
Jewish Study Bible.
I think it is an excellent
introduction to the complexity
of this material.
The most salient feature of the
Deuteronomistic School is the
conviction that Israel's
residence in the land is a
function of its obedience or
disobedience to the covenant
with Yahweh.
And that conviction is going to
color its presentation,
its evaluation and its
interpretation of Israel's
history and her kings from
Joshua right through to 2 Kings.
Yehezkel Kaufmann uses the term
"historiosophy" which I have
written up here,
historiosophy,
to describe this material.
Where a historian might simply
record events (as if that is
such a simple thing to do,
but let's go with that for a
moment)--a historian might
simply record events,
however selectively or
partially, might try to indicate
cause and effect where possible;
but a historiosophy is a more
conscious philosophy of history.
It's seeking to ascertain the
meaning of events to draw larger
philosophical,
ideological conclusions from
the events of history,
and to point to the larger
purpose or design of history,
not to say just what happened,
but to say why it happened and
what it means for us today that
it did happen.
So the Deuteronomistic history
is not simply a history of
Israel until the destruction of
Jerusalem, it is a
historiosophy.
It is making an argument and
it's attempting to communicate
the meaning and the significance
of the events of that time,
and it does so through a
pattern, a literary pattern we
will see, of reward and
punishment.
This is an important point,
and as we begin to go through
the material,
we will be coming back to this.
We will return to this idea.
There are certain key features
of Deuteronomistic thought that
are evident from Joshua through
2 Kings.
One is the belief in the divine
election of Jerusalem.
Jerusalem is the city that is
referred to in Deuteronomy when
it says God will choose a place
to cause his name to dwell.
In the Deuteronomistic books,
that place is going to be
Jerusalem.
There is also a belief in the
divine election of David as the
king of Israel and his dynasty.
Now, it's interesting because
the other four books of the
Pentateuch never mention a king.
In Genesis through Numbers none
of the legal materials say:
when you have a king this is
what he shall do.
It is only the book of
Deuteronomy that assumes or
prepares for a monarchy and
contains legislation for a king,
and the things that he should
do.
So this, again,
underscores the connection
between Deuteronomy and the
following books.
Deuteronomy assumes a king.
It is being written and
redacted at a time when there is
a king in Israel,
there have been kings in
Israel,
and it is providing laws for
the construction of an ideal
monarchy.
So David, the theme of David as
the elected king of God,
David also as the ideal king,
is something else that is a
theme of these books.
Another theme that we see in
these books or feature of the
Deuteronomistic School is the
emphasis on what we call the
Yahwist prophets -- prophets
like Elijah and Elisha.
These prophets are held up as
heroes and champions of
religious purity.
They are completely against any
kind of mixture of Yahweh
worship with other elements,
any kind of syncretism.
The other thing we see in the
Deuteronomistic material is a
preference for Judah,
the Southern Kingdom,
as compared with a very
negative presentation of the
Northern Kingdom,
Israel.
The Northern Kingdom Israel is
going to come in for very,
very bad press at the hands of
the Deuteronomistic writers,
which shows that they probably
favor or come from Judah.
So the northern kings are going
to be uniformly denigrated.
They are going to be denigrated
because they maintain cults that
rival the central sanctuary of
Jerusalem.
And this is going to be what
does them in.
The other theme that we see
throughout the Deuteronomistic
material is the negative
presentation of the Canaanites.
But we will talk more about who
these Canaanites were and how
complicated, in fact,
that presentation is.
Now, the books of Joshua and
Judges that open the
Deuteronomistic history,
these books recount or relate
the story of the conquest of the
land of Canaan by the Israelite
tribes,
and the early years of the
settlement: that's in Judges.
To gain an understanding of
some of the issues involved,
and the emergence of a tribal
structure in the land,
it's helpful to know something
about the geography of Israel,
which is why I have handed out
for you a couple of different
maps,
but one that gives you physical
features (and that is on the
top).
It has often been pointed out
that in the past 4000 years more
wars have been fought for the
possession of the tiny strip of
land known as Canaan,
or the land of Israel,
or Palestine,
than have been fought for
almost any other area in the
world.
And in the ancient world,
the reason for this was that
this very small rectangle--;it's
about 150 miles long and 70
miles wide,
about the size of Rhode
Island--this very small
rectangle lies on the way to
anywhere worth going in the
Ancient Near East.
You've got Egypt over here.
You've got Asia Minor up here,
and you've got Mesopotamia over
here.
Not a tremendous amount of
inherent value in this strip of
land, but it is important for
where you could go by traveling
through it.
So you have three main trade
routes that cross the country,
and they were used by trading
caravans that would carry gold
and grain and spices and
textiles and other goods between
Egypt and the rest of the
Fertile Crescent and up into
Asia Minor.
So control of these
international highways brought a
great deal of wealth to the
area,
but the central location was a
double-edged sword,
because in times of peace it
would bring prosperity,
but, of course,
in times of war the land was
perpetually invaded as armies
would crisscross the land going
off to do battle with the great
powers.
So on their way to conquests in
Egypt, or Asia Minor or
Mesopotamia, armies would tramp
through the land.
And that explains the
succession of rulers that have
held the region:
the Egyptians,
the Amorites,
the Israelites,
the Assyrians,
the Babylonians,
the Persians,
the Greeks, the Greek
Ptolemies, the Seleucids,
the Romans, and the list
continues as we go on into the
medieval and the modern periods.
Now, despite the fact that this
is a very small piece of land,
it boasts great geographical
diversity.
So there are three main
geographical subdivisions.
You can see them on your map,
and they really run in strips
from north to south.
If you look at your map you
will see first on the west side,
you've got a low coastal plain.
It is about 20 or 30 miles wide.
It is the coastal plain,
and that provides,
or that is the main highway out
of Egypt or down to Egypt.
That area was controlled by
Egypt at the purported time of
the Exodus.
Running north to south,
next to that coastal plain,
is a region of low mountains.
These low mountains are cut by
some valleys that sort of run
east-west: you will see one
there, the Valley of Jezreel,
in particular;
that was a particularly fertile
valley.
So the valleys that cut through
the mountains are extremely
fertile.
The Plain of Megiddo also joins
with the Valley of Jezreel.
That is the most fertile part
of the country,
but it was also the site of
many of the most bloody battles
in Israel's history.
Then next to that north-south
central hill country,
you've got also running north
to south, what we call the Great
Jordan Rift Valley.
It goes the entire length of
the country.
And the Jordan River runs
through this valley.
It rises in the Sea of Galilee
or the Kinneret in the north,
and then it flows about 65
miles, I believe,
down to the Dead Sea.
At the northern extreme of the
Rift Valley, is Mount Hermon,
which is the highest point.
It is snow covered,
Mount Hermon.
And that is the highest point
in Israel, it rises about 10,000
feet above sea level.
The central mountain area,
those are between 4000 and
10,000 feet above sea level.
As you move from the central
area over to
Jerusalem--Jerusalem is about
2,500 feet above sea level--but
then as you continue moving east
towards the Rift Valley,
that area is dramatically lower
-- and you feel it as you travel
the road there,
just how quickly it drops,
so that by the time you get to
the Sea of Galilee you are 700
feet below sea level,
and the Dead Sea is nearly 1300
feet below sea level.
That is the lowest point on the
earth's land surface--so this
dramatic drop in just a very
short geographical area.
Up in the north,
the river is surrounded by very
lush vegetation on both sides,
but there is no life 65 miles
south down by the Dead Sea.
This is because the water is
25% salts and minerals--although
I hear they found some sort of
bacteria or something there,
so I guess I should not say
anymore that there is no
life--but essentially there is
no life we would care about in
the Dead Sea area.
So it is a very desolate area.
And tradition identifies this
as the site of Sodom and
Gomorrah.
The area around the Sea is
basically semi-desert.
We call this the wilderness,
the wilderness of Judea between
Jerusalem and the Dead Sea,
the wilderness of Judah or
Judea.
So within this relatively tiny
area there are radically diverse
regions, and this fact held
important implications for
Israel's history.
Unity was difficult.
Being somewhat isolated,
the inhabitants of each region
developed a distinctive economic
and cultural character.
You have the small settled
farmer in the more fertile
areas.
You have semi-nomadic shepherds.
You have city dwellers.
You have merchants and traders
who are handling the commerce on
the trade routes and enjoying
broader cultural contacts.
So that's the geographical
setting for what we are about to
read in the Book of Joshua.
The structure of Joshua is
really somewhat simple.
We can really divide it into
two major parts.
The first 12 chapters form a
unit that conveys the invasion
and conquest.
There are certain important
elements.
In chapter 2 we have Joshua
sending out spies to scout out
the land.
In chapter 3 we have the
account of crossing the Jordan
River.
In chapter 6 we have the Battle
of Jericho.
The story of the Battle of
Jericho is really a composite of
two accounts that have been
woven together into a single
narrative.
So in one of them Joshua's
warriors seem to march silently
around the city seven times.
In another, the priests carry
the Ark around the city 13
times, so scholars think there
are two different accounts here
woven together.
Chapter 8 describes the victory
at a place called Ai,
which is near Jericho.
Chapter 9 tells the story of
the Gibeonites who join the
Israelites;
they are a local group that
seems to join them.
And then 10 and 11 give us two
further military campaigns.
Towards the end of 11,
we have summary statements.
In Joshua 10:40,
we read: "So Joshua defeated
the whole land,
the hill country and the
Negeb"--;that's the desert here
to the south--;"and the
lowland"--so you have the hill
country,
the low land--;"and the slopes,
and all their kings;
he left none remaining,
but utterly destroyed all that
breathed".
Chapter 11 goes on to stress
that Joshua completed the task
that had been begun by Moses.
In verse 15:
"Just as the Lord had commanded
His servant Moses,
so Moses had charged Joshua,
and so Joshua did;
he left nothing undone of all
that the Lord had commanded
Moses."
And again, in verse 23,
the insistence:
"Thus Joshua conquered the
whole country,
just as the Lord had promised
Moses;
and Joshua assigned it to
Israel to share according to
their tribal divisions,
and the land had rest from
war."
So Chapters 13 and 21 go on to
describe the division of the
land among the tribes and then
we have some sort of tidying up
at the end.
The remaining chapters are
appendices: 23 is a farewell
address, and 24 is a renewal of
the covenant at Shechem,
which brings everything to a
nice conclusion.
So the narrative in the first
part of Joshua,
Joshua 2 to 12,
describes the invading
Israelites as an organized
confederation of 12 tribes whose
conquest is accomplished in a
few decisive battles under the
military leadership of Joshua.
And the disunited Canaanites
put up little or no resistance:
they're paralyzed by a fear
that is sent by God.
All of those who were conquered
are put to the ban or the
herem--that's the sacred
devotion of objects and persons
to God,
which entailed killing them,
so they were utterly destroyed.
So the first half of the book
of Joshua contains a
streamlined, idealized account
according to which the
Israelites managed in a
relatively short period to take
the central hill country,
confining the Philistines to a
little strip here on the coastal
plain.
We will come to the Philistines
in a minute.
The account of the conquest in
Joshua 2 through 12,
is concerned to express the
basic idea that Israel's
victories would not have been
possible without Yahweh,
without his wondrous help.
It was Yahweh who divided the
Jordan before them.
It was Yahweh who broke down
the walls of Jericho.
It was Yahweh who put fear in
the hearts of the Canaanites.
Yahweh was present at every
battle.
The Ark was a visible sign of
his presence and it marched
before them.
And soon after the conquest
representatives of all of the
tribes of Israel are going to
meet and make a solemn covenant
at Shechem to be the people of
Yahweh, to worship him alone.
And according to the Book of
Joshua, Israel's tribal
structure assumed its classical
form at this time.
This is a very neat picture of
the rapid conquest of Canaan,
but it's at odds with
statements elsewhere in Joshua
and in the book of Judges.
For example,
the victories in Chapters 2
through 10 are confined to a
very small area,
what would actually be the
tribe of Benjamin basically,
so just one small area.
In Joshua 13:1:
Joshua 13 opens with the
statement that Joshua was old,
advanced in years,
and there was much of the land
remaining to be possessed.
In Joshua 10 (which is in the
first part of Joshua--Joshua 10)
verses 36-39 report the conquest
of several cities in the south,
including Hebron and Debir.
But in Judges,
we read that they had not been
captured: they were captured
later, after Joshua's death.
Joshua 12:10 reports the defeat
of the king of Jerusalem.
In Judges 1:8 and 21,
we read that the people of
Judah did this (conquered the
king of Jerusalem) and that
despite that victory they failed
to actually drive out the
inhabitants,
the Jebusites, who lived there.
And it is not until King David,
200 years later that,
in fact, we will read about the
capture of Jerusalem.
Judges 1 gives a long list of
the places from which the
Canaanites were not expelled.
Also archaeological evidence
contradicts the picture in
Joshua.
In the Ancient Near East,
destroyed cities tended to be
leveled, and then a new city
would just be built on top of
the ruins,
and you would have these slowly
rising mounds--each one of those
is called a tell (so you
may have heard of Tell Dor?).
These are mounds which
represent the successive layers
of destroyed and rebuilt cities.
And excavations will reveal the
destruction layers under the
floor of new cities.
So following the biblical
account, we would expect
evidence of a thirteenth century
destruction of Canaanite cities.
And archaeologists for a long
time were convinced that they
would find these destruction
layers.
But they were disappointed.
They have found really no
evidence of extensive conquest
and destruction in thirteenth
and twelfth century
archaeological layers.
Some of the sites that are said
to be destroyed by Joshua and
the Israelites weren't even
occupied in this period,
the late Bronze Age,
beginning of the Iron Age;
the Iron Age begins around 1200.
Excavations at Jericho and Ai
indicate that both of these
towns were laid waste at least
200 years before the probable
time of Joshua;
so there weren't even any walls
in Jericho at the time of
Joshua.
Of 20 identifiable sites that
were said to be conquered or
captured by Joshua and the next
generations,
only two show destruction
layers for this time,
Hazor and Beth-el.
And yet interestingly enough,
Hazor's capture described in
Joshua is contradicted elsewhere
in the Bible,
because in Judges 4 and 5,
it is still a Canaanite city.
It is said there that it is
still a Canaanite city and
Joshua failed to take it.
So the conclusion one can draw
from all of this is that Joshua
2 through 12 is a kind of
ideological construction,
the significance and the
purpose of which we will come
back to in a moment.
But clearly the formation of
the nation state,
Israel, was much more
complicated than the picture
that's presented in Joshua 2
through 12.
Scholars have proposed three
possible models to explain the
formation of Israel.
The first is an immigration
model.
This was first posed by German
scholars.
Since the main Canaanite cities
that existed in the land at that
time were fortified or walled
cities down on the plains,
the Israelites,
it's thought according to this
model, would have entered and
they would have occupied the
very sparsely populated central
highlands.
They would slowly have begun to
take control of the plains
coming down from the highlands.
Well, we do know that at the
end of the late Bronze Age,
beginning of the Iron Age,
around 1200,
this was a time of great
upheaval throughout the
Mediterranean world.
We have the collapse of
Mycenaean civilization.
We have the Trojan Wars.
The Hittites are invading Asia
Minor, modern day Turkey to the
north.
And these upheavals are leading
to mass migrations,
migrations of people.
Many are sailing from mainland
Greece and from the Greek
Islands, and they are flooding
this area,
the coasts of Phoenicia,
the coasts of Canaan and Egypt.
And these people are spoken
about in a lot of our ancient
sources.
They are referred to as
"peoples of the sea," coming in
from the sea,
from islands and coastal areas
of the northeastern
Mediterranean.
One of these peoples of the
sea, one of these groups,
inhabited an area here:
Perasta or Pelasta.
The word "Palestine" comes from
this, Peresta,
Palesta or Philistines.
It is all the same root.
And so a group if these sea
peoples comes in and occupies
this area.
They will be the Philistines,
the area that is now the Gaza
Strip.
And they found the five
Philistine cities that you will
hear about increasingly in the
book of Judges:
Gaza, Ashkelon,
Gath, Ashdod and Ekron.
The idea of the immigration
model is that Hebrew settlement
would have probably occurred at
about the same time in the
latter part of the thirteenth
century.
The Hebrews could take
advantage of all of these
upheavals and the weakened hold
of Egypt.
Remember Egypt had control of
this area but their grasp was
weakening with the flood of
people coming in from the sea
and other migrations.
Their hold was weakening and
the Hebrews would have been able
to take advantage of that and
enter in and occupy areas in the
central highlands.
The problem with the
immigration model,
again, is the archaeological
record.
Archaeologists have,
indeed, found several sites in
the central hill country --
which is pretty exciting--and
they were clearly newly
established in the thirteenth,
twelfth, eleventh centuries.
So clearly something new was
happening in the central
highlands at this time.
They extend throughout the
land, but mostly the central
highlands.
And these are thought to be
Israelite, especially because
they appear in places that the
Bible identifies as strongholds
of Israel.
Remember also,
you have the Merneptah stele of
1204, in which the Egyptian
pharaoh boasts that he managed
to wipe out Israel.
It is obviously a hyperbolic
boast, but the point is it shows
that there was an identifiable
entity, Israel in Canaan,
by 1204.
These new thirteenth century
settlements, however,
are in their material culture,
that is to say their pots and
their jars and their houses,
entirely Canaanite.
The inhabitants seem to have
been peasant farmers,
like other Canaanites.
One interesting difference is
the absence of any pig bones,
which is kind of interesting.
But in any event,
this suggests that these
settlements were established
peacefully, not by a group
coming in and conquering.
Maybe they emerged from within,
rather than being established
by peoples immigrating from
without.
So there are two other models,
then, models different from the
immigration model,
two other models for
understanding the formation of
Israel, that build on this
archaeological evidence.
The second model is what we
call the revolt model.
The revolt model proposes that
Israel began really as a social
revolution within Canaan.
We do have a set of letters.
These are letters that date
from the fourteenth century BCE.
They were written by people in
Canaan to the Pharaoh in
Egypt--remember the Pharaoh
still has control over Canaan at
this time.
And in these letters there are
lots of complaints about groups
that are causing turmoil and
upset in Canaan.
They are challenging Egypt's
rule.
And these people are called
Habiru, or Abiru.
They were not an ethnic group
so much as a marginal social
group of people in revolt,
if you will.
Some have suggested that
Israelites escaping from Egypt
may have joined with these
disaffected Canaanites in
revolt,
known as Habiru,
these trouble makers,
to establish their own
settlements and to worship a
liberator god,
Yahweh, rather than follow the
rule of Pharaoh.
A final model,
then, is a model of gradual
emergence, which simply holds
that Israelites were basically
Canaanites who had developed a
separate identity and settled
increasingly in the central
highlands.
They withdrew and settled in
this area.
The theory doesn't try to
explain why they separated.
We don't know.
Perhaps it was disaffection.
Perhaps they were pushed out by
the invading sea peoples.
And maybe it was something else.
But they withdrew for some
reason.
And how and why they took up
the worship of Yahweh or the
cult of Yahweh isn't really
clear;
but it seems to have been what
marked them as distinct from
other Canaanites.
The Yahweh cult may have been
introduced by people escaping
slavery from Egypt.
Most scholars see the Exodus
story as evidence for the
presence of some escaped slaves
among this community.
So the important thing is that
the Hebrews at this stage were
probably not a united people.
Various elements went into the
final mix that would emerge as
the nation Israel:
local Canaanites who,
for some reason,
withdrew and established their
own settlements,
with a continuous material
culture,
and established agricultural
lifestyle--you have them.
You have escaping slaves from
Egypt.
And remember,
we do have some evidence of
destruction from outside,
so there could also have been
some foreigners coming in and
destroying and settling.
It even seems that some local
foreigners were admitted to the
community.
We read of Midianites who
covenant into the community .
We read of Kenites who covenant
into the community.
And archaeology supports this
picture of merging of peoples,
a picture of the merging of
peoples,
rather than conquest or even
large-scale immigration,
because the new settlements in
this period show such continuity
with the past,
not a complete break,
not the initiation of something
radically new.
And, again, some of the
elements within this group may
have brought with them the story
of a miraculous escape from
Egypt.
They may have understood this
to be the work of Yahweh,
a god known probably from
southern regions.
And so the mixed group that
would join together to become
Israel accepted Yahweh,
though perhaps not exclusively,
and adopted the national story
of the Exodus as its own at some
point.
The Hebrew tribes,
themselves, were likely still
in the process of formation.
But the tribal structure of
Israelite society that would
develop would be strengthened by
the natural division of the land
into these separate geographical
areas: that only reinforced the
tribalization of society.
And these local tribes probably
did assimilate elements of the
local population.
We've really seen already the
ethnic mix of various elements
reflected in religious imagery
and institutions.
We've seen that Yahweh is
represented in terms reminiscent
of the tent dweller,
El, the god of the semi-nomadic
tent-dwelling Hebrews and their
patriarchs,
and certainly a god of the
Canaanite pantheon.
We have seen that Yahweh is
also represented in terms
reminiscent of Baal of the
Canaanite pantheon,
the God of the settled
Canaanite population.
In fact, in the book of Judges,
you will read of a temple to
Israel's God,
the God of the Covenant,
and that temple is called the
Temple to the God of the
Covenant or Baal Berit.
The word "berit" means
covenant.
It is referred to as Baal Berit;
it's referred to as El Berit or
Baal El Berit;
and this is in reference to
Yahweh.
These terms are all used to
describe the God of the
Covenant.
So in short,
we really may hypothesize a
union of cultural,
religious and ethnic elements:
local Canaanite agriculturists,
semi-nomadic Hebrews perhaps,
of the Exodus,
escaped slaves,
perhaps Habiru/Abiru,
a disaffected group that is in
revolt.
All of these would come
together to produce what would
be a new political and religious
reality called Israel.
If so, why does the book of
Joshua provide such a different
account, one of outside conquest
by means of a war led by the
hosts of the Lord?
Because in this account
military skill is much less
important than ritual
preparation and purity.
The Israelites march around
Jericho for six days with seven
priests carrying seven horns and
the Ark of the Covenant,
and then with a blast and a
shout the walls tumble.
The conquest is represented as
a miraculous victory by God.
That's emphasized in Joshua
24:12.
It was God, not the sword or
the bow, that drove out the
enemy.
And why the claim of the utter
destruction of the Canaanites
when evidence points to close
Canaanite origins?
This practice,
which I mentioned before and is
known as herem or the
ban, is not unique to Israel.
I know some of you have studied
it in sections:
you looked at the inscription
of King Mesha,
King Mesha of Moab.
There is a very important,
famous inscription from the
ninth century BCE,
written by King Mesha of Moab
Moab is to the southeast of the
Dead Sea,
so King Mesha of Moab.
And in the inscription he
writes, he boasts:
"And the god Chemosh said to
me, go, take Nebo from Israel.
So I went by night and fought
against it from the break of
dawn until noon,
taking it and slaying all 7000
men,
boys, women and girls and maid
servants, for I had devoted them
to destruction for the god
Ashtar Chemosh",
referring to herem.
It is likely that such claims
are hyperbolic in Moab,
and it is likely they were
hyperbolic in Israel.
But that does not lessen the
shock value for a modern reader,
even though war in our time is
no less savage and no less
brutal.
But the important question here
is why a biblical writer or
editor would want to insist that
the Canaanites were to be
completely destroyed.
I think assertions of national
identity and independence are
often predicated on
differentiation from others.
If the Israelites were,
in fact, basically Canaanites,
who had withdrawn from the
larger collective,
who insisted on the
overlordship of Yahweh,
then Canaanites who did not
join them in this were a special
threat to the new Yahwism.
This same dynamic of intense
sibling rivalry appears again in
the first few centuries of the
Common Era,
when some Jews separated from
others and in differentiating
themselves and creating their
own identity as Christians,
felt it necessary to engage in
devastatingly vituperative and
violent rhetoric against their
fellow Jews.
The interesting thing,
however, is that we must not
ignore another voice that's in
the biblical text,
and it is a voice that adds a
level of complexity to this
picture.
Because alongside the idealized
portrayal of the Israelite
conquest in the first half of
the book of Joshua,
alongside the call for the
destruction of all Canaanites,
we find interesting tales of
alliances and incorporation of
various Canaanite groups.
Indeed, who was one the
heroines of the Battle of
Jericho, if not a Canaanite
woman, a prostitute no less,
named Rahab.
She declares her faith in
Yahweh and she delivers the city
into Joshua's hands.
The biblical writer saw fit to
preserve and include this
account of a heroic Canaanite
prostitute.
Another Canaanite group,
the Gibeonites,
trick the Israelites into
making a covenant with them,
and it is a covenant the
Israelites then feel bound to
observe.
Michael Coogan has described
such stories as etiological
tales.
They are attempts to explain
the fact that there are lots of
Canaanite groups included in
Israel;
and we need to understand and
explain that reality as much as
we are conveying an ideological
account in which all Canaanites
are obliterated or destroyed.
At the very least,
these stories raise questions
about the biblical portrait or
portrayal of invasion and
conquest.
And at most,
they illustrate the biblical
writers' taste for literary
subversion yet again,
something we will see over and
over.
The imperative of preserving a
distinct identity--based on
giving up the worship of other
gods or older gods and observing
all that is written in the law
of Moses--is reiterated in
Joshua's farewell address in
Joshua 23,
and in the covenant renewal
ceremony in 24.
And the central idea is that
there is one proper response to
God's mighty acts on behalf of
Israel,
and that is resolute observance
of the book of the Torah of
Moses, without intermingling
with the peoples that remain.
So in Joshua 23:7-8:
"Do not utter the names of
their gods or swear by them;
do not serve them or bow down
to them, but hold fast to the
Lord your God as you have done
this day."
And verses 11 to 13:
For you own sakes,
therefore, be most mindful to
love the Lord your God.
For should you turn away and
attach yourselves to the remnant
of these nations--to those that
are left among you--and
intermarry with them,
you joining them and they
joining you, know for certain
that the Lord your God will not
continue to drive these nations
out before you;
they shall become a snare and a
trap for you,
a scourge to your sides and
thorns in your eyes,
until you perish from this good
land that the Lord your God has
given you.
In 24, the Israelites are
assembled at Shechem to renew
the covenant,
and Joshua recounts God's
mighty deeds on behalf of Israel
and exhorts them to choose whom
they will serve:
Yahweh,
who has done all of this for
them so undeservedly,
or the gods of those whose
lands they are settling in.
And the people are warned of
God's jealousy.
He demands exclusive loyalty.
He will not tolerate any
deviation in the service of
alien gods.
The ban on intermarriage here
is quite specific.
It is directed against
Canaanites only,
not all non-Israelites,
for a very specific reason:
religious purity.
Marriage with Canaanites,
the people closest to you,
specifically,
will lead to the worship of
that spouse's god,
and Israel is to show undivided
loyalty to God,
or God will take the gift of
the land from her as he did the
Canaanites.
One last remark for you to
think about.
Consider the position of the
Israelites in the sixth century,
the time of the final editing
of the Deuteronomistic history.
The Israelites are sitting in
exile in Babylon.
They are trying to make sense
of the tragedy that has befallen
them, the loss of their land.
Consider how a text like Joshua
23 and Joshua 24 would go a long
way towards explaining their
fate while retaining faith in
Yahweh.
We're going to return to this
when we reach the conclusion of
the Deuteronomistic history in 2
Kings.